hello everybody and welcome to another
1our flipping challenge today I'm going
to be doing something similar to last
one except I'm going to be starting with
5 mil I kind of really liked the
challenge of starting with a lesser
amount of money uh because it really
gives a different Dynamic to the
challenge uh whereas having unlimited
amount of money you can kind of just
Brute Force any category into being kind
of good where here you might have to be
a little more strategic about it um I'm
planning on possibly doing one with only
one mil start uh just to see what kind
of items would work for that cashtag
people seem to be interested in that uh
so if you are definitely leave me some
feedback in the comment section and yeah
let's get
started all right so we're starting with
5 mil today and I thought I would take a
little bit more of a different approach
today I'm not really going to be doing
any uh high volume items uh because
it'll be pretty obvious how much money
I'm going to get with 5 mil only to
start with uh I'll be able to do maybe
two high volume flips at a time and I'll
slowly get around to making maybe 100
200k Maybe uh so we're going to try to
mix it up and this time do some uh
medium expensive items so I'm going to
do items like uh the Trident of the Seas
and we might try a fury ornament kit
that being said let's get the 1 hour
underway okay so this is what uh the two
items I've been looking at Trident in
the ornament kit uh the reason I found
these is because I just filtered using G
tracker um to just have a 5 mil item or
less and then I put a minimum buying
quantity and selling quantity of at
least the five PR hour so we have a look
at the fury ornament kit uh looks like
uh the approximate offer price is around
40 or 3460 or something like that uh so
we'll put an offer in for the fury
ornament kit
61 and we can just afford one of those
and uh the other item I was looking at
is the Trident of the Seas uh not as big
a margin but might trade a lot more
frequently uh we'll try buying it for
uh we'll try this approximate offer
price again uh at about $12.90 and we'll
just put one offer in for $12.91 and
then that's pretty much all our money
guys so 5 mil is not a lot so we're
going to hope uh that we can actually
flip a couple of these more expensive
items and uh yeah come back when
hopefully some of these have bought Okay
so we've successfully bought a trident
for $12.91 only took about 5 minutes and
we're hoping to sell it for about uh
1309 so about a 20K profit but still not
too bad all right so we actually bought
a fury ornament kit uh for
3461 and they're hoping to sell it for
about
3499 sure $34.99 uh which be a 40K
profit not too bad on top of that I
actually found the ancient page 2 as
well uh which looks like it has a very
large margin for 20K on this item is
very good uh we'll go put an offer in
for like
170 ancient page two
and
170k and just go for one to begin with
here and we stld off the ornament kit
easy 40K not too bad so we'll go ahead
and buy another one of those uh for
3461 and uh yeah happy how this is going
so far all right and we came in with the
Trident flip now uh I wasn't zelling
because it's such a highly traded item I
dropped it down and we sold it for I
guess a n 60k profit not very good so
we'll probably not do that item again
looks like the trees in the ring might
actually have a pretty good margin on it
221 into 7 or 721 to 769 uh pretty good
oh my God the ancient page too nice
tree zo how [__] you right trees in this
ring I'm a [__] idiot uh for
722 and uh we have the ancient page to
and it had a pretty good margin on it uh
we're going to try to sell it for I
guess we don't have that here um try
999 and uh yeah so we'll come back oh we
got the trees in this ring nice uh
722 and uh we're going to pop that in
for and maybe
769 that is a pretty nice profit for the
amount of money and we'll go ahead and
buy another one oh no we can't quite
afford that never mind okay and we're
back with an ancient p cage flip that is
insane we sold it for
250k and bought it for
175 that is a 75k profit on the ancient
page which is just incredible go ahead
and buy another one of those for sure um
I we go by we'll go by two is probably a
better idea 175 and go for two okay I
think we're going to switch up this or
ornament kit for a quicker item and I'm
thinking The Archers ring it's right in
the 3 mil range and um tends to have a
lot more traded per
hour uh yeah look at that 8069 that's
great uh let's look at the margin here
uh it doesn't look like much on GE
tracker so we're just going to have to
kind of guesstimate it um what's the
average price say
um archers
ring we'll try it at
36 37 we'll do the actively traded price
here and yeah we'll maybe get a 15 20K
profit on that but um we should
hopefully be able to trade um the full B
limit because we have 40 minutes left
these things trade a lot and we do have
another ancient page coming in that's
awesome sell that off for
$249 perfect and yeah still waiting for
the trees in this ring to sell but
pretty happy with these items so far
okay so we're back and we've sold the
Tre trees in this ring uh for 765 that
is a decent profit but 40K so we'll go
ahead and buy another one of those and
we have the Archer ring coming in for
3638 and I think we're going to try to
sell it
for
3652 we'll try that Archer Rings don't
tend to have a very big margin on them
uh but again they do trade more often
and yeah ancient page still wasn't sold
but uh we'll wait on that okay so it
looks like The Archers ring has coming
at 3649 had to drop it down by about 3K
uh it's going to leave us with a 11k
profit not too bad let's see if we can
FP more of these quickly and yeah that's
about it okay and we have had a Archer
ring come through again and another
trees in this ring do not know why I
can't say that word and we'll s off for
3649 36
49k and um the treasonous ring we're
selling for
for 765 pretty decent on that
one
765 and uh no more of these ancient
Pages have come through so I think we're
going to leave it on the one that we
have now and oh no it doesn't cost us
very much we'll just leave it like this
all right there's another Archer ring
sold uh 3649 going to go for another one
38 and we'll have to start counting how
many of these we flipped because we can
do eight so that's uh one two okay six
more okay I think we're going to flip up
the item um The Archers ring I mean it's
working but it's just not a big enough
margin for the time invested uh so
another item I'm looking at is the
dragon chain body trades a lot looks
like it could have a big margin right
now uh we'll try buying it
for9
something Dragon chain body
let's just go for one z99 and we'll go
for two of those and we can actually get
another item then and I think we're
going to try the Elder chaos Hood as
well put an offer in for about
108 Elder chaos
Hood one
z019 and yeah I'm going to try these
items out hopefully they work uh and we
get a better profit from them okay wow
we actually bought the two train uh
train bodies chain bodies
uh really quickly for
1099 and we'll try selling him
for uh I don't know let's see what was
it
at uh dragon chain bodies only for about
11 14 or something like
that
um it's not a huge margin but that's 20K
for only about 2 m invested where the um
the Archer ring was only about 10 mil or
10K for about 3 and half mil invested so
this is a much better return uh the
treasonist ring is sold for 765 uh we'll
go ahead and buy another one of those
really good item so far
722 and uh yeah this ancient page
doesn't look like it's going anywhere uh
take that out and probably drop this
down a bit probably got lucky on that
one uh try
739k Co
and it looks like we actually got a
Elder chaos Hood coming in and now this
did look a lot more promising so we're
going to try putting it in
for uh
1069 how
about and uh we'll probably try going
and buying another one of those cuz we
just have enough Capital to do that
1019 and yeah looking good okay so we're
back again with a treasonous ring coming
in 723 we did bump it up we kind of do
this a little bit as we get closer to
the end more likely someone is undercut
me and we're going to sell it for 765
again getting some pretty consistent 40K
flips on this items we probably gotten
the most money from the trees in this
ring uh which is pretty awesome uh we
have a dragon chain body coming in for
119k in profit so nice all right and
just a second later uh we did sell the
Elder chaos hood for a 50k profit really
happy with that one and uh maybe we'll
go find another item we still have 26
minutes left uh let's look on G tracker
here go refresh the highest margin page
all right we'll put an offer in for Holy
sandals at about
615 uh holy
sandals
616k and we'll go for two maybe we can
get that many and we sold off all the
dragon chain bodies for 1109 that's a
20K profit so not too bad and we'll go
ahead and buy some more of those all
right there's another treason rank
coming in for
765 pretty happy with this item
definitely going to keep trying to flip
it not sure if we're going to hit a
limit anytime soon all right G tracker
says the limit is eight so we must be
hitting that pretty soon uh but I guess
we'll keep doing it uh until we do all
right we have one dragon train body
coming in for
1099 uh again we're getting a 10K profit
on this so not that good but pretty
quick item to be honest quicker than the
Archer ring actually I think the Archer
rings are just so contested uh that it
just makes it no fun for anyone so it's
good to kind of pick some other items
okay we have an elder chaos Hood coming
in for
1019 and we'll go try to sell it again
for 1069 that is a really good margin on
that 50k
1069 and yeah pretty happy with that all
right we're back and we've sold the
dragon train body that's a 10K profit
the holy sandals have actually come
through too for 617 and we're selling it
for
640 try 640
five maybe how about okay and there's
another Elder chaos Hood coming in at
1069 that is amazing definitely going to
go back and buy another one of those for
1019 all right and we have another
Dragon chain body coming in for 1099
maybe we can sell for a little bit more
now
maybe
one 119 try going for another extra 10K
uh cuz it has been a while and we it
took about 10 minutes bu that last one
which makes me think the price May gone
up a bit all right we actually sold it
for 119 1119 yeah 100
1.12 mil pretty well uh that's a 20K
profit there which is pretty nice uh we
only have coming on 15 minutes now so I
think we could still try to buy another
Dragon chain body but after that we may
cut it off all right there is another
Elder chaos Hood coming in for
1019 see if we can sell it for
1069 I'm not sure which item is better
now the treasonous ring and the Elder
chaos hood are the MVPs by far uh but
we're getting a slightly better margin
on this item but probably sold less it's
kind of up for debate all right and like
a second later we have another treas
this ring coming in for
723 uh we're going to try this out for
765 all right and we sold the holy
sandals uh for 645 I was not sure if
we're actually going to sell those or
not and uh 15 minutes left I mean it
can't really hurt at worst I lose like
10K Maybe and we have another Dragon
chain body coming in for one zero
um oh
[__] a God damn it I messed that up uh
okay one n9k unfortunately we kind of
derp those offers up I think I think
we're going to put another offer in for
The Elder chaos Hood hope that we can
buy one more before this hour is up uh
one19 and then I think we're going to
pull out the offers uh cuz that'll
pretty much be time I think at that
point and and we sold another treas in
this ring
765 okay never mind we're going to put
one more offer in we must have hit this
limit already I can't believe we haven't
already all right there is another Elder
chaos Hood coming in for
109 that's going to be our last one for
sure uh selling it for 1069 H definitely
not going to have any more time to sell
any more of
these uh now for the treasonous
ring um we'll leave that in for another
until 10 minutes and then we're going to
pull out all our buy offers and just
focus on selling them all right we have
another pair of holy sandals coming in
for
617k and uh we're hoping to sell them
645k and uh we did sell the uh dragon
chain body for 1109 oh
what that's really weird 11 126k okay
I'll take it all right we sold the holy
sandals for 645 really good item uh I
wish I had a little more time to flip
this that is another 30k in profit for
something that only cost 600k and I
think uh we're going to pull out the
treasonous Ring We may very well have
hit the buy limit also and then we're
just going to focus on selling these
last three items uh with just the 10
minutes remaining all right guys and
we're back and uh we only have about 15
seconds left so uh we didn't sell off
the last two items unfortunately uh we
did sell one of them so we're just kind
of waiting but we only have 10 seconds
left so it's not super likely uh and the
ancient page 2 never saw gold uh so we
might take a hit on that uh but overall
I think we did pretty well for the hour
timer's up uh so we'll pull these two
items out and uh we're going to have to
dump them here so uh uh 162 that's not
bad that's just a 13k loss and uh dump
this
for a little bit less again we bought
this for 123 so this is not looking like
too big a loss one8 so that's only a 7K
loss on that so I'm not too bad in total
from flipping these items for 1 hour we
managed to get
538k in profit that is pretty good
that's about 10% uh return on all the
money that I've invested so 5 mil was
our start and we got about 500k uh the
best items by far were the Elder chaos
Hood uh treasonous ring and um holy
sandals actually came in pretty pretty
clutch near the end I guess and yeah
hope you guys enjoyed the video if you
want to see more uh flipping challenges
kind of like this with lower mounts and
uh so kind of showing the different
strategies involved uh please uh leave a
comment if you're interested and I will
see you guys in the next video
[Music]